What's up. My fellow
gamers that's right everybody.
Can we get some gamer in the chat.
If we get 5000 gamer types I'm
gonna do a special surprise for you guys to make sure you smash
like on Video. This is me.
*POG*
I bet you wonder how it ended up in this. My
name is to appear in this is my story.
Hey guys. Welcome to my first
Vlog. Jesus. So there's a lot of stuff that I haven't
done in this game that are yet to be explored.
Let's go to the market shall we. I am
so frickin hype guys.
Well I keep playing the game wrong that's for sure.
That's kind of cute. OK.
Where are you.
I found you at last.
Hey watch it. Wait i know
I can do it. Way wait. I.
Got you now. Whamen. Oh God. God.
Hey chill. Don't. Hey hey hey. You're hitting my
shield. That's just your friend. Stop.
You're hurting her. Stop it. Gosh
darn it. All right. We're gonna have to go. We're gonna have to bounce.
We're gonna have to bounce.
This is not what I wanted at all. Stop.
Everyone just stops.
Think about what you're doing. You're hurting the children.
Where am i?
Your fried tomato.
Gosh darn it. All right. I'm gonna have to plan B.
Plan B everyone. Plan B Plan B.
It's Knee time baby.
Oh. She's blocking the knees they've
adapted
Stop blocking the knee. They stuck.
I got your knife stuck in his knee.
I need you to stop. I need you to stop. Listen
Why wont you just stop. How do they keep
spawning.
I thought this is easy.
This game is impossible. Well I could have
gone better
Let's get it Let's get a bigger weapon. It's frickin
spear time boys. Yeah. This is.
It's. The famous Swedish Stance
Huh. Oh my God I'm so sorry.
Oh my God I'm so sorry. God.
I didn't mean I swear to God I swear to
God man. Don't come near me.
Don't come near me. Do not. Get.
Up or down up. HA. HA. HA.
OH OH OH OH.
OH. OH
Oh. WATCH FOR IT.
There IT IS.
GOD DAMN there's so many
It's hard to hit him.
Oh okay. I got him I got him.
Okay
Okay okay. Peace. Peace peace
please. I've gotta have friends.
God damn it there's so goddamn many of them.
What am I supposed to do. Desperate
times call for desperate measures men.
Da da. Da
God dammit it's stuck on his knee it's fricking it's
stuck in his knee
.
I'm legit trying here. It's so goddamn hard.
Swedish boy. Hi. Hey. Hey
Look this. Look at this. Look at this. Look at that huh.
Hey. Hey
Hey look at this. Look at this. Look at me.
What's this. What's this. That's your
knees. Get a slice.
Yes. God damn it so
many of them. Huh. Hey
Yoink.
Anyone else
want some of that. It. All
right all right. Okay okay. I need a drink guys.
Oh.
Oh hold on guys.
Hold on guys. Just give me this. OH.
OH.
Oh I FEEL SO GOOD. IS THAT THE LAST
ONE. IS THAT THE LAST ONE. ARE YOU THE LAST ONE.
LISTEN WE DON'T HAVE TO FIGHT. LISTEN.
It's JUST YOU AND ME.
No one is watching.
Jesus I almost died in
game life.
Stop fighting. Stop bullying.
Everyone (We have an announcement to make)
Please please.
You messed with the wrong boy.
Swedish boy.
You'll regret this. You'll regret this.
Daddy and big
Daddy and son is gonna go for a little walk.
What's that.
It's over for you. This is it. What's that.
Okay. I don't care. What you want
another one. Okay. I don't care. Daddy
and son it's gonna go on a little adventure
aren't you. Aren't you excited. Aren't you excited.
Tell me how excited you are.
It's time. Now. Tell me.
Where is T-Series
Damn it. Where are they. Tell me now.
And no one gets hurt.
Stop by
All right. Well that was epic.
Boo boo boo. Oh.
Oh. Face
me. Hey. Hey. Hey. Hey.
Hey. Hey.
Hey.
Swedish boy
Very angry. Oh
you did not do that.
Oh god there so goddamn many of them.
Stop
It does not have to be this way. We could be
friends we could be lovers we could be
best mates.
You just hit your friend
Idiot.
Nice ponytail.
Loser.
Just sit down sit down. Women aren't video
games. I've been telling you. For millions of years.
Evolution did not come through this. Stop blocking.
I swear to God if you block another. I'm almost dead.
I'm almost dead. Huh. Huh. not like
this. Not like this. I give up. You win
you win. I'm sorry
Have you heard of the legend of Darth
Plagueis the Wise.
Oh sorry about that.
You're in good hands now. monsieur.
Don't worry. Daddy Poods is not going to do
anything bad.
Give me your weapon.
What. Was that.
You are sorry. You
apologize. Well that's a little too late now isn't
it. Now little boy.
If you do an epic break dance. I would
consider forgiving you. Break it down. To me now.
Oh. Wow. He's got all kinds of moves.
Damn you're really good at this. All right. Go away.
Now. Stay down.
He's still alive. Don't worry we're just gonna have to amputate
your knees. Your freaking knees are gone
they will never walk
again.
Off
You go back.
What do you got. Oh two at time. Oh two at a time. Now is that
how we're doing it.
Hey I got your friend. Just kidding.
Bye
Bye. Sorry.
Show
Up some.
Bye bye now huh.
Oh wow. It looks like I'm totally
undefeatable. Subscribe to Pewdiepie.
Okay. I think it's time to stop.
You want pyramids. We got em. Oh you're
into castles huh. We got you covered baby. You want
some pents. Easy.
We got it. all
*Sponsor Eagle*
this game is still relevant. God damn it.